- [Narrator 1] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
- [Narrator 2] We are the paradoxical ape,
bipedal, naked, large-brained, long the
master of fire, tools, and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got there, an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
- [William Ruddiman] This is kind
of the transition talk between the
relatively deep past and the very recent
past and present and future, so there is a
debate going on about this. I'm talking
about the last 10,000 years, when
agriculture developed. There is a debate
going on or discussion going on in the
community. If you asked the average
geoscientist "Are humans now in control of
the world, the atmosphere, the water,
the soil, everything else?" I think you'd
get pretty much a 100%
response "Yes."
The debate or discussion is about whether
to define a particular time when that
began and on that, there is less
unanimity, and I'm somewhat toward one
extreme of that argument. I was asked to
write a prospective piece, and I'm sorry
this is not the most exciting slide in the
world. You can at least read the title,
and it's about this discussion and about
this, about defining this epic we live in.
Whether to do it in a very recent time,
and there's a proposal out from a group in
London, geologists, cartographers to make
it the 1945, 1950 era because all kinds of
things started to happen that humans
hadn't been doing before then.
And because bomb testing began then and
these isotopes that people have been
talking about were spread widely in the
ocean and the ocean sediments and in ice
cores, and so there is a move afoot to say
the Anthropocene, the start of the human
domination of the planet, is in the 1950s,
and this slide shows a dark-colored bar
down the right center part which defines
that era. It actually shows the industrial
era, which is the last 200 years, and
there is substantial support for this
suggestion to do to this.
However, some of us who work back on
somewhat longer time scales favor a longer
interval of human influence on the earth
extending back about 10,000 years to the
earliest major domestication and dispersal
of crops and livestock and a series of
things that happened and accelerated
since that time.
So that's what I'm going to talk about.
I'm going to take you back 10,000 years
and tell you what we were up to as we
became agricultural people. There's been a
community sense - this is a kind of
cartoon version I drew about five or six
years ago of the little figure that is in
the right insert on your program, and this
is pretty close. It's a schematic.
You notice that nice wrinkle in the
deglaciation point, so you're coming from
glacial cold temperatures up into
interglacial, the modern interglacial
warmth. It peaks out and then it starts to
decline slightly towards the present, and
now we are taking off into worlds unknown
with the Industrial Revolution. This is
the picture of climate for the last 20,000
years that prevailed through the 1900s
right to the turn of the century.
Here's a picture I think is correct. You
notice it is the same from the glacial
cold era coming up into the warmth, but
around 8,000 years ago in this slide,
something else starts to happen, you see
agriculture originating at the bottom of
the slide. And agriculture produced
greenhouse gas effects. There is no
disagreement about that, but there is big
disagreement about how much is the
amplitude of these greenhouse gas effects.
So the proposal is that these
anthropogenic greenhouse gases kept the
climate from getting as cold as it would
have without the gases, and that in fact,
early farming stopped nature from taking
us back into the beginnings of a new
glaciation sometime in the last maybe
2,000, 3,000 years. So early farming
stopped deglaciation. It sounds radical,
but I'll take you through the steps.
There are two ways to think about this. So
these are greenhouses gases that are
recorded in ice cores as you have already
learned. Air in the ice cores preserves
the amount of green house gases. Here are
two examples of this.
The red dots show for methane at the top
and carbon dioxide at the bottom. Those
are the values during the last 11,000
years, the time scale along the bottom.
There you see them both peaking, methane
and carbon dioxide peaking about 10,000
years ago, starting to decrease, then
climbing. Carbon dioxide comes back up
after about 6,000 years ago. Methane comes
back up after about 5,000 years ago.
Also plotted on this slide in blue, dark
blue circles, is an average of the seven
previous interglaciations, and you've seen
that they were about every 100,000 years.
There was an interglacial climate due to
those variations in earth's orbits. You'll
see that starting with methane, there was
a peak in methane about the same time as
the red circles for this interglaciation,
and then there's a decrease, not
dissimilar to this interglaciation. But
then instead of turning around and going
up, this average of all seven previous
interglaciations keeps going down and the
same things happens with CO2 with an even
more striking match of the current
interglaction and the average of the
previous interglaciations, and they part
ways about 6,000 years ago.
I call this top-down evidence for human
influence, and the way to think about it
is really simple. If the blue circles show
previous interglaciations when no one
thinks humans were having massive effects
on earth's environment or its atmosphere,
if blue is natural and if blue is going
down, then red is not natural and so
something new is working in this
interglaciation. So something I say that
humans are doing 6,000 years ago starts to
push the CO2 curve upwards and starts to
push the methane curve upward about 5,000
years ago -- so anomalous
and I say anthropogenic factor.
I call that a top down view because it's
from the point of view of the atmosphere,
and that is half a hypothesis. If you want
a full hypothesis you need bottom-up
evidence. What is happening on the ground
? What are people actually up to? This
slide is a very simplified version of the
spread of agriculture. You can see, and
here I'm mapping mainly the spread, and
not the initial domestication
of crops and livestock.
You can see in Southwest Asia, the Eastern
Mediterranean, after about 9,000 years ago
crops which originated in the Fertile
Crescent started to spread across Europe,
down into the Nile River Valley, went east
into Pakistan and India. About the same
time in Northern China, people
domesticated crops and animals and that
spread at the beginning of the Han
Dynasty, the Han people I should say,
spread up into Korea and then the rest of
China. And then around 5,000 years ago in
Southern China, the development of
irrigated rice spreads across down into
India, down into Southeast Asia, the
Philippines, so those are
major centers of domestication.
Around 5,000 years ago, the Bantu people
in tropical North Africa and sub-Saharan
Africa developed sufficiently impressive
agriculture that they spread all across
southern Africa except for South Africa
itself, one of the major
migrations of human history.
Over in the Americas, in Mexico, even
though agricultural began earlier by 4,000
years ago the combination of corn, beans,
avocados and tomatoes. People were
spreading agriculture up into North
America and down through Central America.
And finally in the Eastern Andes, part of
the Amazon, more agriculture beginning
there 4,000 years ago. All of those are
happening during the time when those
greenhouse gas trends were going
the wrong way.
So to go back to the methane curve shown
at the top, remember there the departure
is 5,000 years ago.
Here's a map of the spread of rice
agriculture through Asia. It originates
and the Yangtze River Valley.
By 5,000 years ago, rice is fully
domesticated, and it spreads down into
across the rest of Asia by 1,000 years
ago, and this is based on archaeobotanical
work. Now rice patties are man-made
wetlands, and wetlands are basically
swamps which have swamp gas which is
methane which bubbles out of the rice
patties. So the spread of rice agriculture
coincides nicely
with the reversal of the methane trend.
The man who did this, who is Dorian Fuller
at University College London, converted
the spread of rice, and then assumed
infilling of the density of rice into
estimates of total rice area. Irrigated,
that's in green, and he converted that
using modern relationships to estimates of
the effect on atmospheric methane, and he
got a 70 parts per billion estimate
between 5,000 and 1,000 years ago. The ice
core data which I showed you earlier shows
a 100 parts per billion rise, so if his
estimate's right, and there are going to
be more versions of this I'm sure, rice
irrigation would explain 70 percent of the
rise in the methane trend. Remember also
the full anomaly also would include the
fact that the methane trend should have
gone down but it didn't, so there is more
to explain.
Dorian Fuller also mapped the spread of
livestock across Africa and Asia, and you
see that between 7,000 and 5,000 years
ago, the livestock are in relatively arid
areas. The Sahara, which is greener than,
it has grasslands because it is getting
some moisture, the Iranian plateau, and
Western China, but between 5,000 and 1,000
years ago rice spreads all the way across
India, livestock spreads across India and
Eastern Asia and down into South Africa
with that Bantu migration, so there will
be estimates of the methane contributions
from livestock too, and they will explain
more of the anomaly.
Carbon dioxide at the bottom until
recently has been very tricky for a number
of reasons which I can't go into in this
talk, but there's been an explosion of
data in the last three of four years that
bears on this. Now to get carbon dioxide
from farming, you need to clear trees and
burn them or just let them rot, which puts
the CO2 in the atmosphere.
Here's a map of the spread of agriculture
across Europe beginning in the lower right
in the Fertile Crescent and spreading all
the way to the far reaches of Europe by
5,500 years ago. Interesting point, 5,500
years ago is still the late neolithic, the
late stone age. We don't even have bronze
age tools, but people are coming in
clearing forests. They are using flint,
very sophisticated flint axes, and so
there is agriculture all across Europe by
5,500 years ago, which is that CO2 curve
starts to rise by 6,500.
That doesn't begin to prove that carbon
dioxide explains that deforestation
explains that carbon dioxide rise, but a
paper published earlier this year
suggests, certainly points, in that
direction. The top left panel shows a
synthesis of hundreds of cores, linked
cores that have pollen remains which
include grass pollen, tree pollen, and
then intermediate pollen. That's shrubs
and things that are in between.
If you look at the trend in Part B, the
dark green forest pollen starts to
decrease somewhere between 6,000 and 5,000
years ago, which is just after that carbon
dioxide curve starts to turn up and go the
wrong way. Before you get to the
industrial era, you've basically gotten
rid of the forests. So this is favorable
to an early anthropogenic effect, a large
early anthropogenic effect. As the top
right shows, its based on
hundreds of cores.
Parts C and D show some data from China,
not pollen data but numbers of
archaeological sites. It turns out the
Chinese government for decades has been
funding people to gather information on
the impressive early history of China, and
there's just thousands of data points,
archaeological data points, either
radiocarbon dated or correlated by
cultural remains to other
sequences that are dated.
So the bottom left slide shows the number
of archaeological sites 8,000 to 7,000
years ago, and they are mostly down in the
Yangtze, down in the Yellow River Valley,
and they are fairly sparse. By 4,000 to
5,000 yeas ago, the Yellow River Valley is
just completely filled in. There are
people burning coal in some of these areas
because the forest is gone, and it's
coming down to the Yangtze River Valley,
and this is before that rice spread begins
in Southern China and the rest of Asia.
So, I guess I could summarize by saying in
the last three or four years there's been
an explosion of evidence, ground-truth
evidence, that people are doing things
that are putting a lot of methane and
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere.
So, this is beginning to gather some
attention from those who report the
scientific news. This is from "Science,"
autumn 2013, this is a piece, a
commentary, that focused on methane, and
you can read the title and get the
punchline yourself. Here's a paper that
was published, a feature's piece, that was
published in the other most distinguished
journal, that's "Nature, " and that the
central panel shows the time of major
effects, cultural effects, upon land
clearance and vegetation, and you see that
there are blocks there that are dating
back to 5,000 years or more. You also see
that methane reversal plotted
in the curve at the bottom right.
So, as we go off on the next few talks
after the break into talking about the
major things that have happened during the
industrial revolution and during the last
50 years, keep in mind that we have a long
history of effecting climate, and the
scope of it is still coming into focus,
but it's coming into focus pretty fast. I
think humans have been a major factor on
the landscape for
thousands of years, not just 200 years.